with roles in the Rocky movies and
Predator Carl Weathers was probably seen
as more of an action or dramatic actor
to much of the general public however he
proved just how hilarious he could be
with a starring turn in 1996's Happy
Gilmore he plays chubs a former golfer
who coach is happy to utilize his
golfing prowess to the fullest extent
waving a fake hand around all the while
think of a place that's really perfect
your own happy place Sandler took to
Instagram to express his at weather's
passing reflecting on what a great guy
he was all around Beyond simply being a
tremendous actor a true great man great
dad great actor great athlete so much
fun to be around always smart as hell
loyal as hell funny as hell loved his
sons more than anything what a guy